zum zweiten mal gravitationswellen
entdeckt jetzt beginnt also tatsächlich
das zeitalter der gravitationswellen
astronomie und wir berichten darüber
heute in klicks um science-fiction am
laser interferometer gravitation wave
absage rhetorikkurs lego ist forschern
erneut sensationelles gelungen und zwar
ein erneuter direkter nachweis von
gravitationswellen dort ein stein
durchlaufen diese gravitationswellen
raum und zeit wenn ein kosmisches
großereignis geschieht durch das die
gravitation von riesigen himmelskörpern
verändert wird das ist zum beispiel so
wenn zwei schwarze löcher kollidieren
dann laufen solche gravitationswellen
durch das weltall und krümmels einstein
sagte diese wellen voraus weil die
gravitation keine kraft ist sondern eben
die krümmung der raumzeit
das heißt also dass uns keine kraft auf
die erde zieht sondern eben die krümmung
der raumzeit also dass die verformung
von raum und zeit uns auf die erde zieht
erklärt wird dass in der allgemeinen
relativitätstheorie verkürzt große
massen ziehen licht an
da liegt aber nicht beschleunigt werden
kann muss die raumzeit gekrümmt werden
also der raum zusammengedrückt werden
damit das licht einen kürzeren weg
zurücklegen kann dieses zusammendrücken
wirkt sich bei uns auf der erde als
erdanziehungskraft aus anfang dieses
jahres haben forscher das erste mal
überhaupt gravitationswellen direkt
nachgewiesen
die wurden vor rund 13 milliarden jahren
durch einen zusammenstoss zweier
schwarzer löcher ausgelöst diese
schwarzen löcher und das konnte man aus
den daten lesen hatten eine masse von
jeweils 29 und 36 sonnenmassen kurz vor
dem zusammenstoß kreisten sie mit einer
geschwindigkeit von viereinhalb 1000
umdrehungen pro minute um einander die
kollision geschah in sekundenbruchteilen
und aufgezeichnet wurden die ersten
daten dieses kosmischen ereignisses am
14 september 2015 um 11 uhr 51 deutscher
zeit eben am laser interferometer graf
international wave observatorio rund
drei monate später am 25
dezember geschah es dann ein zweites mal
die physiker entdeckten jetzt in den
dezember 2015 erhobenen daten erneut
gravitationswellen zitat ich hätte nie
geglaubt dass wir so viel glück haben
nicht nur einen sonnen
sogar zwei nachweise schon in den ersten
beobachtungs monaten zu bekommen unsere
erfahrung mit diesen neuen paar
schwarzer löcher gibt uns die zuversicht
dass wir mit der aktuellen technik sogar
systeme mit sehr kleinen amplituden wie
beispielsweise einander umkreisen de
neutronensterne detektieren können sagte
jack hanna von der pennsylvania state
university
obwohl der ausschlag der detektoren
weitaus schwächer war als der von den
september daten sind sich die physiker
zu über 99 prozent sicher tatsächlich
wieder gravitationswellen aufgespürt zu
haben
gw 15 16 stimmt perfekt mit unseren
theoretischen vorhersagen dafür über ein
wie zwei schwarze löcher einander
mehrere dutzend mal umrunden und
schließlich miteinander verschmelzen
wir konnten sogar feststellen dass
mindestens eines der beiden löcher
rotierte berichtete alexandra bonanno
vom max planck institut für
gravitationsphysik in potsdam ein paar
rätsel unseres universums scheinen sich
also langsam doch zu klären nach dem
sommer 2016 sollen neu und besser
entwickelten detektoren das life projekt
unterstützen
mit den neuen gerätschaften soll es dann
möglich sein eine 200 prozent größere
fläche zu analysieren und jetzt noch
einen mehrwert tipp thema
online-shopping was macht man wenn die
bezahlte ware nicht geliefert wird oder
der online shop pleite geht diese fragen
klärt ich im aktuellen eigentlich
einfach video einfach hier auf das video
klicken also schaut am besten gleich
vorbei und lasst hier likes kommentare
und ein abo da wenn euch dieses video
ihr gefallen hat das gern einen daumen
nach oben
und hier klicken ein kostenloses abo da
schreibt mir auch mal in die kommentare
ob ihr ähnlich gespannt wie wir diese
gravitationswellen forschung verfolgt
und natürlich auch eure meinung dazu und
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran